i think
the culture of celebrity and
entertainment in general is one that
encourages and cultivates a tremendous
amount of selfishness i think it's it's
tough to keep your head on straight
especially when you're at the buffet and
you're allowed to take whatever you want
um
but it's a it's an important part of
surviving it for sure so
what he wants to take over the town like
hiram lodge we stopped hiram we can stop
percival
i don't think percival wants to take
over riverdale
something tells me he wants to destroy
it
riverdale is still a fan favorite show
yeah after six seasons i know you all
have been renewed for season seven
but there's some speculation that the
show is going to come to an end after
that so what do you say to fans who are
wondering
um i mean
i don't really know i'm the actor on it
so i i have no idea what happens
afterwards i know that uh
seven years
you know not to get too technical about
it but seven years is a pretty standard
contract for most actors
um so
generally it's safest to just assume
it'll run for seven years but we're
lucky enough to have run for seven i
mean that's i think a 22 22-episode
hour-long
show running for seven seasons is
something we might not see too much of
in the future with the streaming models
and and how we're building most shows
and the length of most seasons i i don't
think
this kind of um
this kind of structure for a television
show is gonna exist too too much longer
so it's
i don't know it's a privilege to
it's a privilege to say that we're on
one of those before maybe the model
changes yes
speaking of that there are some people
who are still catching up thanks to
streaming and all of that still catching
up with riverdale how would you explain
the multiverse to them because it can be
a bit complicated for something it can
be
i think we we stuck true to our comic
lineage and because archie comics has
always had a very open
universe you know the predator has come
to visit and we've had a a bunch of
different a bunch of different little
guest stars within the actual digest
comics that we had the potential to
maneuver that way and uh narratively we
decided to go along with
go along with the multiverse idea i
really love it um
now honestly the i think it was the
100th episode
or maybe maybe
i forget the exact one it was when uh
the jughead paradox is truly one of my
favorite episodes in the series i think
it's a love letter to the fans a love
letter to the old archie digest and i
think it was really well done
well looking back over all of the
seasons what is the number one piece of
advice you would give to yourself when
you first started doing the show
looking back now i think emotional
stamina for sure well that's big explain
it's a big one well i think
you know depending on on
the kind of job that you're doing
uh to a greater or lesser extent as an
actor you're sort of dipping into an
emotional well and if you're doing that
for nine months straight for 22 episodes
you have to find an effective way to
refill that well throughout those nine
months in order to have something to
pull off of
that and i think um
i think because we were in vancouver i'm
just getting real with you uh but
because we were in vancouver we
oftentimes didn't experience the fruits
of our labor within a city
that really cherishes film and
television like something like los
angeles as an example so it kind of felt
like when i would come to los angeles
i'd be like whoa and i'd like go crazy
uh i would say you know
if i were to talk to myself six years
ago i'd be like hey man this is actually
it's gonna be quite big keep your head
on straight one more question i have to
wrap with you but you've talked about
refueling yourself emotionally and
recently you also opened up about the
effects that fame can have on children
and your disney channel co-stars
how are you balancing fame in your
everyday life how are you refueling
yourself i think that was the new york
times article and i think specifically
uh while the conversation was around
child stars in that moment i think i
think fame has that effect regardless of
age i i think it really does and i i
think
the culture of celebrity and
entertainment in general is one that
encourages and cultivates a tremendous
amount of selfishness and i think
i think it's important to remind
yourself
that the lifestyle you want to live and
using your job to work towards that
lifestyle is a much more effective means
at a long-term career
than
than working for your job or basing
basing your job around a potential
accolade and an ego that you could you
could acquire
through like the praise and selfishness
that the industry sort of encourages
you know i think it's it's tough to keep
your head on straight especially when
you're at the buffet and you're allowed
to take whatever you want um
but it's it's an important part of
surviving it for sure it's so wise wow
you are
taught me something today thank you
thank you so much